una parte dell'intervento parlato ho
fatto ora quindi posso soltanto dire che
in me convivono anime diverse
non mi piacciono le etichette non mi
piacciono le sbarre nell'arte e pur
coltivando una grande passione e avendo
dedicato dieci anni della mia vita allo
studio del pianoforte dove mi sono
diplomato coltivo anche la passione per
il pop e pur in teatro conservando la
mia giusta rigidità è la mia come posso
dire vocazione a rispettare quello che è
scritto sullo spartito quando interpreto
brani inediti che mi scrivono grandi
autori
io voglio essere libero voglio fare
vedere tutta la mia anima multicolore
sia attraverso la passione per il canto
pop sia attraverso il canto lirico
la canzone che vi canto questa sera è
stata scritta da un grandissimo autore
le cui musiche sono state cantate da
alcuni grandi artisti fra cui posso
citare luciano pavarotti
posso citare celentano posso citare
laura pausini
lui è uno speaker è un compositore qui
al ted e uno speaker che farà
l'intervento nel proseguo di questa
serata lui e daniel vuletic che ha
scritto la musica di questo brano su
testo di francesco tricarico e si
intitola la promessa
rosa blu ti porterai sono dedicate
a te
tempo fa
svaniva in me quella promessa
a di un amore il mio capire ancor non so
rondini vola avanti
ho vestito
biancone
il bel sogno che volevi tu
d
per
cosa sa
io di
tiro
c'è
certo si davanti a dio
ho scelto me stupito ancora sono cosa
posso dare a te
chi
chissà
ap
che cosa sono
mio dio
o c'è
merito si no oddio di
io tempo fa io incontrai amore
è